America's largest bank is making a big
investment in the nation's capital
JPMorgan Chase announced plans yesterday
to open 70 new branches and hire 700
workers in Washington DC Virginia and
Maryland it is part of a five-year 20
billion dollar investment supporting
economic growth in the region CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Glor spoke with
chairman and CEO Jamie Dimon about JP
Morgan Chase President Trump
immigration and a whole lot more 70
branches 700 employees big investment
here why here why now JP Morgan you know
we have about 5,000 branches around the
country and you know because of some
regulatory reform tax reform we have
capital we want to grow and expand so
we've announced her to go into 15 new
markets and 7 order X and why do you
want expansion if you look at the
greater DC area it is the third largest
market when the wealthiest markets in
the country it's all has some of the
poorest neighborhoods when we want to
help lift them up to wages are up some
bonuses have been given one of the
concerns though is is that the vast
majority of the benefits from this tax
reform has gone to companies and
executives and share buybacks that fair
I don't think it's gone to executives
per se but like I said the immediate
benefit it would there would be
immediate benefits where companies are
doing right now to help grow and expand
and wages and stuff like that over time
Cal gets reinvested and that drives
productivity and wages and so the
American public understand that's what
drives it question being on bett but are
the benefits of its of tax reform right
now being distributed in your estimation
fairly over time they will but I said it
could be very hard to do it in day one
but remember it for me to open 500
branches I need real estate people I
need to train tellers we need trained
branches we need to sign leases I
couldn't couldn't do it overnight House
President Trump doing well I'm not going
to speak specifically regulatory stuff
good I think a lot of people I speak to
CEOs have seen relief but let's just
reduce the bureaucracy which you all
know is there and anyone who deals with
government and the DMV or the VA sees it
all the time how often do you talk to
the president not a lot when you talk to
him what do you say well I'm the
chairman of the Business Roundtable so I
go for very specific things and it was
trade we spoke about trade we spoke of
immigration about the policy issues that
we're trying to give them our insight
and what we think would be good for the
country you disagree with him in part on
both trade and immigration but also
agree with him in part immigration I
don't know because it's not completely
clear with the administration's on the
broad spectrum of immigration I've heard
him say publicly
I support daca I've heard him say
publicly I want to get immigration
reform done but of course it's all
wrapped up in border security and things
like that so I'm not an expert in
immigration policy but if we're up to me
I try to get the immigration fix you
know it's tearing at the body politic
there's been a lot of talk about North
Korea we know that Mike Pompeo outgoing
CIA director potentially Secretary of
State went to visit Kim jong-un the
president's really trying to advance
that potential summit which might take
place in June good idea I think it's a
great idea I mean how can trying you
know to have peace and the Korean
Peninsula would be wonderful for the
world and you know I even find it funny
when people say don't try of course you
should try if it doesn't work it doesn't
work but I think the fact that pump air
went there is a very good sign and
hopefully that they will come to a
resolution I think everyone would want
that including China Russia or hopefully
Russia
do you see China as a threat we should
work with them they do compete
economically and I want to compete with
the Chinese banks but there's no reason
we can't do it together and help each
other president says the great relations
with President Xi they should continue
that for the sake of the world thank you
to Jeff Glor of CBS Evening News